you have a brand new chart that you
included this order book visual i've
never seen this before so you're gonna
have to explain to us what exactly is
going on here because it looks beautiful
but uh maybe confusing both to me and to
other people yeah totally so this chart
actually isn't the the order book stuff
um i think i've thrown the order book
charts in there before i use trading
light for that um but i i've talked
about order books because it kind of
relates to the bottom section so to
start off with with what i was saying
about order books you see a pretty
strong confluence of bids right across
60k across several major exchanges but
as we've talked about before these
orders can be spoofs
and so basically like you can use these
big bitter ask walls to generate
liquidity for the opposite you know
let's say
i like to use examples to explain things
um let's say you know you you think
price is going to go higher but price is
starting to run away from you near this
huge whale where you can set a giant ask
wall it's essentially the cell wall
and you can kind of cap off the price
right and no retail guy is going to want
to sell into that because it's a huge
order
and so what they're actually doing is is
they can use that to actually fill buys
on the other end of that because they're
generating liquidity
right below their their
ask wall in that case or conversely
let's say
the market's starting to go down and
they want to get out of their position
but you know they can't they can't start
market selling because they'll incur a
lot of slippage and price will just
start running away from them what they
can do is they can set a massive bid
wall and they can actually be filling
cells as p as they're generating
liquidity because retail doesn't want to
um retail what doesn't want to sell into
that giant wall buys right
and so they can use these things to kind
of get in maneuver in and out of
positions it's not as straightforward as
oh you see a big bid a large bid so that
means that it's you know
automatically bullish and there's like a
huge wall
bull whale sitting there waiting to
scoop up coins it's a bit more nuanced
than that but with that being said um i
do think like a lot of traders are
saying these bids in confluence with 60k
just being a really strong level like
suzu was joking around saying like the
great wall of 60k you know i think over
the last week or so you've seen that
hold up as a pretty strong level and
keep in mind you know we're just ranging
you know the last couple days um but
that 60k level when you look you know
and this this gets to this chart this
chart is looking at all the liquidation
levels so we can see
you know let's say price gets below x
number well there's a lot of
liquidations there right and so what you
see and i kind of highlighted this in
this little black box is all those those
pink lines are showing you there's a lot
of long liquidations and particularly
people who are 25 x long um and in that
in that little cluster there and that's
right below 60k
and so what i'm what i'm trying to say
here and i know i kind of sound like i'm
saying well price could go up or down
right um and first of all you know i
don't have a very strong opinion about
the price in the short term other than
we're probably going to get a large move
because of we talked about you know
volatility's the volatility squeeze
um but with that being said
if we do get below 60k with volume if we
see a high volume breakout then i think
you'll probably start to see these long
liquidations
you'll start to see like a cascade of
longs get liquidated because you can see
all those levels set just below um 60k
in that chart there so this is something
that i've started looking at recently
but have never thrown in the newsletter
before but i look at it in confluence
with funding and then also like uh we've
talked about the convexity that coin
margin open interest has i look at it in
confluence with that so you know like
you know theoretical bear case would be
like an enormous amount of liquidations
under under a certain price level um you
know you're seeing funding rising as
price keeps going down and they're all
coin margined open interest you know
coin margin contracts that are being
opened and you can see that in open
interest like that would be like a
theoretical you know bearish scenario
but
yeah just another thing to use in
confluence with some of those other
metrics